mehr auslandseinsätze der bundeswehr die
verteidigungsministerin will
deutschlands außen- und
sicherheitspolitik neu ausrichten ein
streik mit folgen
fast 200.000 lufthansa passagiere
bleiben am boden
die airline will jetzt aber wieder mit
der flugbegleitergewerkschaft reden zum
arzt per computer oder handy deutschland
für tabs auf rezept ein online
sprechstunden und die digitale
patientenakte
nachrichten nicht da das heute mit
christian sieber sind die wunden heilen
und herzlich willkommen bei uns um 7
kristin otto nachher mit dem sport und
glücklichen fußball einen guten abend
eine neue ausrichtung für die deutsche
außen- und sicherheitspolitik nichts
weniger als das fordert die
verteidigungsministerin heute annegret
kramp karrenbauer hat in einer
grundsatzrede gesagt deutschland müsse
auch militärisch aktiver werden um seine
strategischen interessen zu schützen
das wäre ein schritt für dieses land
bisher sieht es so aus
mehr als 3000 bundeswehrsoldaten sind
aktuell im ausland im einsatz darunter
tornados in jordanien zur luftaufklärung
im kampf gegen terror miliz und
ausbilder in mali westafrika um die lage
dort zu stabilisieren
die verteidigungsministerin will mehr
die bundeswehr soll wenn nötig das
spektrum militärischer mittel voll
ausschöpfen
und sie fordert einen nationalen
sicherheitsrat aus militär diplomatie
und wirtschaft mehr von cornelia
schiemenz stillgestanden für die
inhaberin der befehls und kommandogewalt
vor der versammelten zukünftigen
führungseliten der bundeswehr macht
annegret kramp karrenbauer klar
deutschland darf angesichts der krisen
in der welt nicht länger vom rande aus
zuschauen
und das gilt vor allem bei der lösung
von konflikten
hier sollte sich deutschland wie der
damalige bundespräsident gauck gesagt
hat ich zitiere früher entschieden und
substanzieller einbringen deutschland
solle gestaltungsmacht werden so die
ministerin
dazu gehört letztendlich auch die
bereitschaft gemeinsam mit unseren
verbündeten und partnern das spektrum
militärischer mittel wenn nötig
auszuschöpfen
alle militärischen mittel ausschöpfen
das heißt robustere mandate mehr
auslandseinsätze annegret kramp
karrenbauer nennt maly als beispiel wo
sich deutschland zwar engagiert aber es
eben die franzosen sind die gegen den
terror kämpfen
wer die lippen spitzt er muss auch
pfeifen und das betrifft die materielle
und personelle einsatzbereitschaft der
bundeswehr den verteidigungshaushalt und
deswegen sind jetzt taten gefragt also
ein sofortprogramm materielle
einsatzbereitschaft ausrüstung
haushaltsfragen etc pp kramp karrenbauer
weiß um den zustand der truppe
unterstreicht nochmals mehr geld in die
verteidigung stecken zu wollen
international trifft das auf zustimmung
die europäer sollten ihre
verteidigungsausgaben nicht steigern um
der nato oder den amerikanern zu
imponieren sondern weil es in ihrem
ureigensten sicherheitsinteresse ist
annegret kramp karrenbauer steht seit
wochen in der kritik nun holte sie zum
befreiungsschlag aus doch sie wird sich
daran messen lassen müssen wie viel aus
ihrer heutigen grundsatzrede tatsächlich
umgesetzt wird
ja und die sind innenpolitischen punkt
am ende den nehmen wir jetzt noch mal
auf mit chakuza banerjee in berlin
chakuza guten abend wie viel ist denn
jetzt profilierung einer ministerin
und wie viel echte mögliche neuordnung
kann man das sagen
wenn sie wirklich eine neue ordnung
wollte dann hätte annegret
kramp-karrenbauer das ganze
wahrscheinlich anders angehen müssen sie
hat es ja nicht in einem cdu gremium
vorgeschlagen sie hat sich auch nicht
mit dem koalitionspartner spd abgestimmt
ohne den das ganze sicherlich nicht geht
und zum praktischen wert dieses
vorschlages hat sich heute schon angela
merkel geäußert sie hat gesagt den
vorschlag gab es schon einmal vor
einigen jahren man hat ihn nicht
durchgekriegt es sei eben an der spd
gescheitert und im übrigen sei dieser
vorschlag eher etwas für ein präsidiales
system wie zum beispiel die usa in
deutschland mit vielen
koalitionspartnern oder
koalitionskonstellationen sie stoße so
etwas nicht auf große gegenliebe mit
anderen worten ein rohrkrepierer mit
ansage ein rohrkrepierer sagen sie und
jetzt erinnern wir uns ja an den syrien
vorstoß von annegret kramp karrenbauer
was heißt das für sie wenn jetzt auch
dieser neue vorstoß ebenfalls verkaufen
sollte
sollte das ganze verpuffen und sollte
sie jetzt nicht nachlegen dann würde sie
das mit sicherheit schwächen denn wer so
große visionen vor stellt der muss auch
zeigen wie er sie umsetzen möchte und
dafür braucht es eben verbündete dafür
muss man mehrheiten organisieren wenn
das nicht klappt dann zeigt sie relativ
deutlich dass sie zwar mit vorschlägen
in die debatte ein steigt dann aber
nicht wirklich bis zu ende denkt und
guckt wie kriege ich das ganze auch
durchgesetzt und dann wird die frage ob
annegret kramp-karrenbauer als
kanzlerkandidatin für die union
irgendwann ins rennen gehen kann
sicherlich lauter und das ist vermutlich
nicht in ihrem sinne
die analyse live aus berlin chakuza
herzlichen dank dafür und wir bleiben
noch einen moment beim thema auch der
französische präsident mahnt heute eine
neue sicherheitspolitik an
und er fällt dabei auf weil er mit
ungewöhnlich drastischen worten die nato
kritisiert der zeit sei deren hirntod zu
beobachten sagte emanuele marco in einem
interview bei strategischen
entscheidungen gebe es keinerlei
koordination zwischen den usa und den
europäischen nato-verbündeten die
reaktion von kanzlerin angela merkel das
sei nicht ihre sicht ein solcher
rundumschlag sei nicht nötig zitat auch
wenn wir probleme haben unser nächstes
thema frust bei lufthansa passagieren
heute der streik der flugbegleiter lässt
viele maschinen nicht mehr abheben
und jetzt kommt bewegung in die sache
die lufthansa will ihren konflikt mit
der gewerkschaft ufo per schlichtung
lösen
insgesamt hat die airline 1.300 flüge
für heute und morgen abgesagt betroffen
sind 180.000 passagiere
die gewerkschaft will für die 21.000
flugbegleiter höhere spesen und zulagen
im grunde geht es aber darum ob die
lufthansa ufo als verhandlungspartner
anerkennt oder nicht stefan schlosser
berichtet streiks sind immer das letzte
mittel
die flugbegleiter wollen die lufthansa
treffen und treffen doch vor allem die
passagiere aber natürlich flug begleitet
natürlich auch ihre ihre rechte und so
durch durchkriegen und manchmal bleibt
dann halt nur steigen
die lufthansa hat sich da bis zur
letzten minute nicht zeit genommen bis
man das herausfinden konnte internet
aber da unser flug glücklicherweise geht
betrifft es uns jetzt dann doch nicht
einmal im jahr hängig mindestens drin
mit lufthansa es geht nicht meiner
meinung
bis zuletzt hatte die lufthansa versucht
den streik auf dem gerichtsweg zu
verhindern ohne erfolg jetzt bewegt sich
der konzern das unternehmen wolle mit
allen drei gewerkschaften der kabine
gespräche aufnehmen erklärte lufthansa
chef carsten spohr heute dieses schließt
ausdrücklich auch wieder gespräche mit
der ufo ein mit dem ziel im interesse
unserer kunden und mitarbeiter die
gestern von der ufo angebotene
schlichtung zu vereinbaren
monatelang herrschte funkstille so
besteht weiterhin misstrauen bei der
gewerkschaft aber auch bereitschaft für
gespräche das zumindest der
konzernvorstand uns schriftlich
mitgeteilt hat ja wir wollen dieses
wochenende mit euch in konkrete
verhandlungen eintreten wie wir aus
dieser krise herauskommen und das
versuchen wir
wenn es nicht klappt müssen wir am
montag verkünden dass es weitere streiks
gibt
am wochenende wollen sich beide seiten
hinter verschlossenen türen zusammen
setzen
reisende der lufthansa sollten die
daumen drücken während einer schlichtung
gilt dann die friedenspflicht weitere
streiks wären erst einmal vom tisch
jetzt gucken noch mal kurz hinter die
kulissen dieses doch besonderem streiks
das geht im mittelpunkt also nicht um
höhere löhne sondern darum ob die
lufthansa mit dieser gewerkschaft ufo
verhandeln muss die lufthansa sagt nein
die gewerkschaft will sich mit diesem
streik also quasi beweisen peter theißen
beobachtet dass am frankfurter flughafen
peter kann man sagen wer da jetzt am
ende am längeren hebel sitzt ja man muss
aus heutiger sicht sagen dass die
strategie der lufthansa erst einmal
gescheitert ist monatelang hat man ja
jedes gespräch mit der ufo verweigert
man hat wohl darauf gesetzt dass interne
streitigkeiten bei der ufo dem kranich
konzern letztendlich in die karten
spielen würden das ist nicht passiert
stattdessen hat die lufthansa dann mit
anderen gewerkschaften verhandlungen
geführt nun eine schallende ohrfeige
gestern vom frankfurter arbeitsgericht
das frankfurter arbeitsgericht hat
nämlich eindeutig festgestellt dass die
ufo tarifverhandlungen führen darf das
hat die lufthansa ja immer bezweifelt es
geht also jetzt in die nächste runde und
es bleibt vor allen dingen für
viele beobachter auch ein ungutes gefühl
nachdem der lufthansa-chef nun quasi
eingeknickt ist bleibt die frage warum
das ganze
und hätte hätte man das nicht vermeiden
könnte dieser streit dieser streik hat
ja sehr viel geld gekostet und es bleibt
die erkenntnis dass man das mit etwas
mehr rücksicht und mit etwas mehr
weitsicht leicht hätte wohl vermeiden
können
der frankfurt vielen dank anderes thema
anderthalb wochen lang hat die thüringer
fdp auf eine zahl gstaad die 5 um gerade
mal fünf stimmen lag sie bei der
landtagswahl über der fünf prozent hürde
beim erstmal ja nur vorläufigen
endergebnis jetzt ist alles ausgezählt
das amtliche endergebnis ist da und die
liberalen haben es geschafft sind wieder
im thüringer landtag mit 73 stimmen über
den schicksalhaften 5 prozent das
schicksal der syrischen flüchtlinge
treibt die welt um seit jahren viele von
ihnen sind in der türkei präsident recep
tayyip erdogan hat heute wieder gedroht
die türen zu öffnen und die flüchtlinge
nach europa zu schicken sollte er nicht
mehr unterstützung bekommen
laut erdogan betrifft es rund 3,6
millionen syrer in der türkei mehr will
dass möglichst viele von ihnen zurück
gehen freiwillig wie er sagt und so
werden hunderte flüchtlinge regelmäßig
über die grenze gebracht unter anderem
nach afrika aber auch in die zum teil
zerstörte stadt aleppo oder ins
umkämpfte idlib
anne brühl berichtet
es fließen tränen an diesem morgen in
snj dem größten bezirk von istanbul das
bürgermeisteramt hat busse organisiert
die syrische flüchtlinge zurück in die
heimat bringen sollen
ich habe keine angst zurück zu gehen
warum sollte ich ich gehe freiwillig
weil das geld nicht reicht und wegen der
lage hier
und die ist gegenüber flüchtlingen
feindseliger geworden nationalismus
wirtschaftskrise viele türken empfinden
die flüchtlinge im land als belastung
190.000 von ihnen mussten istanbul
bereits verlassen hat gerade der
innenminister erklärt niemand der legal
eingereist ist haben wir des landes
verwiesen
wir haben alle dorthin zurückgeschickt
wo sie registriert sind
und genau das ist das problem
viele flüchtlinge sind nicht in istanbul
registriert entschließen sich deshalb
zur rückkehr nach syrien
auch in regionen wie et le pin denen es
immer wieder zu kämpfen kommt mit toten
und verletzten unter der
zivilbevölkerung
menschenrechtsorganisationen warnen
nicht jeder gehe freiwillig februar
leute sahen sich zwang ausgesetzt sogar
drohungen oder physischer gewalt damit
sie die papiere über ihre freiwillige
ausreise unterschreiben
und sie wurden gewaltsam nach syrien
deportiert einem der gefährlichsten
länder der welt in einen konflikt zu 150
syrer machen sich in snj auf den weg
zurück es ist eine reise in eine
ungewisse zukunft zurück nach
deutschland online sprechstunde mit dem
arzt und auf dem smartphone warnt eine
app bei bluthochdruck auch kranke sollen
von der digitalisierung profitieren sagt
gesundheitsminister jens spahn und hat
dazu jetzt ein ganzes paket an gesetzen
auf den weg gebracht vieles davon kommt
auch gut an aber damit krankheiten
besser erforscht werden können will
sparen auch patientendaten sammeln
anonymisiert und in dem punkt reagieren
manche allergisch sandra susanka schon
heute werden sie gesammelt
abrechnungsdaten über patienten die
erlauben rückschlüsse zum beispiel über
chronische krankheiten oder
krebserkrankungen
was wir ändern ist dass diese daten
zügiger und etwas umfangreicher für die
forschung zur verfügung stehen
wichtig ist für diejenigen die damit
forschen wollen stehen die daten nur
anonymisiert zur verfügung das heißt es
ist auch sichergestellt dass der
einzelne versicherte dass er nicht
zurückverfolgt werden kann
genutzt werden sollen die daten von rund
73 millionen gesetzlich versicherten vor
allem für langzeit forschungen und
analysen von behandlungsabläufen trotz
pseudonymisiert gibt es
datenschutzrechtliche bedenken es wird
an vielen stellen patienten patienten
helfen aber wir brauchen vertrauen in
diese digitalisierung wir brauchen
vertrauen in den sicheren umgang mit
daten und deswegen muss es eine
widerspruchsmöglichkeit geben bei der
verwendung solcher daten in forschungs
datenbanken auch bei den neuen
gesundheits apps kann man keinen
einspruch bei der datenweitergabe
einlegen
sie gibt demnächst auf rezept so
dokumentieren apps für diabetiker die
blutzuckerwerte andere sollen
unterstützen arzneimittel regelmäßig
einzunehmen was aber nicht geht ist
gleich apps die noch gar nicht ihren
nutzen erwiesen haben schon in die
finanzierung mit aufzunehmen
das wird auch im praktischen leben nicht
wirklich passieren oder so zu einem
guten ergebnis führen keinen streit gibt
es um das elektronische rezept seit
heute gibt es das mancherorts aufs handy
in der video sprechstunde verschrieben
so aus der wissenschaft jetzt ein fund
den die forscher als sensation
bezeichnen
das hier ist so ein menschenaffe der vor
rund zwölf millionen jahren im heutigen
deutschland gelebt hat seine überreste
wurden jetzt im allgäu gefunden
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass udo
der erste menschenaffe war der aufrecht
gehen konnte muss die
evolutionsgeschichte also neu
geschrieben werden
antworten von sven klasse nur ganz
vorsichtig und mit handschuhen fasst sie
die knochen an forscherin madeleine
böhme fast 12 millionen jahre alt sind
sie die knochen eines menschenaffen
gefunden im allgäu
sie sehen die ist ziemlich komplett
die zelle ist also sagen unterarmknochen
und sie sind es etwa in der größe von
von mir
so soll er einmal ausgesehen haben der
so genannte danubius gucken wo sie der
einfachheit halber auch udo genannt das
spektakuläre an dem fund die neu
entdeckte menschenaffenart konnte
aufrecht gehen die forscher lesen dass
aus den gefundenen gelenken und aus
hinweisen auf die wirbelsäule
diese fähigkeit gab es bei menschenaffen
so bisher noch nie auch nicht bei den
heute lebenden arten dann glaubte bisher
dass das zwei beine gelaufen
eine errungenschaft des menschen es
relativ spät entstanden ist und nun
finden wir es aber bei zwölf millionen
jahren das stellt vieles in frage was
wir bisher das zweibeinige laufen über
die evolution kennen bisher ging man
davon aus dass die wiege der menschheit
ausschließlich in afrika liegt der
mensch von heute mit seinem aufrechten
gang sich dort entwickelt hat der fund
könnte nun vieles auf den kopf stellen
steht jetzt europa das allgäu am beginn
der evolution die fachwelt rätselt
es ist die frage ob dieser diese
fähigkeit sich aufzurichten die
identische fähigkeit ist die wir auch
bei den frühen menschen finden oder ob
die frühen menschen das in afrika dann
unabhängig noch mal erfunden haben
diese frage muss nun weiter erforscht
werden benannt ist udo der zwölf
millionen jahre alte herr übrigens nach
dem musiker udo lindenberg weil man
seinen kiefer an dessen geburtstag fand
und im radio gerade fotos musik lief
sachen gibts jetzt gehen wir zwölf
millionen jahre nach vorne und landen
bei kristin otto erstmals nach fünf
jahren haben alle vier deutsche
mannschaften an einem spieltag in der
champions league gewonnen
nach leipzig und dortmund freuten sich
gestern zunächst auch die bayern über
das dringend angepeilte erfolgserlebnis
nach dem trainerwechsel hansi flick der
neue an der seite mal angespannt mal
aufmunternd am ende erfreut über den
sieg gegen piräus ich habe es genossen
deswegen genossen weil die mannschaft
einfach die qualität die sie hat auch
gezeigt hat natürlich noch luft nach
oben denn bayern tore gab es erst nach
der pause 69 spielminuten lewandowski
blut
münchner aufwand gegen die griechen sein
sechster treffer im laufenden wettbewerb
also im großen ganzen haben wir wirklich
ein sehr gutes spiel gemacht und glaube
auch verdient gemacht
das zweite tor kurz vor ende des spiels
der eingewechselte perisic und bayern
damit vorzeitig in der ko-runde nicht
brilliert aber effizient jetzt wartet
der bvb das ist ein spiel wo sie ganz
deutschland darauf freut und so wir
spielen hier zu hause und wir wollen
natürlich ja hier das spiel gewinnen ein
weiterer sieg und hansi flick hätte eine
gute ausgangsposition für eine
dauerbeschäftigung die trainersuche bei
den bayern ist ja ohnehin nicht einfach
ja große erleichterung bei trainer peter
bosch und bayer leverkusen nach dem
ersten sieg in der gruppenphase der
königsklasse
die bayer elf erkämpfte sich durch den 2
1-erfolg gegen atletico madrid doch noch
eine minimale chance auf die achtelfinal
teilnahme
das wunder von leverkusen wäre durchaus
möglich heißt es mit blick auf die
kommenden zwei spieler
die welt-anti-doping-agentur wada hat
einen neuen präsident wie toll banker
aus polen
der 35 jährige frühere leichtathlet
wurde im polnischen kattowitz einstimmig
gewählt und wird vom ersten januar an
nachfolger des schotten craig wie die
zukunft des kampfes gegen doping beginnt
heute so bank zuversichtlich
das führt natürlich erwartungen ja mal
sehen was kommt vielen dank christian es
wird kälter das kommt auf jeden fall
beim wetter schneeflocken fallen auch
allerdings nicht überall für manche geht
die woche auch mit viel sonne oder
mächtig regen zu ende katja oliver hat
alle details ich empfehle ihnen das
heute journal mit den kollegen claus
kleber 21 uhr 45 für heute danke morgen
gern wieder in allen einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
bislang war der schnee in diesem herz
der mehr was für die höheren gipfellagen
und auch für die alpen wie hier der
blick von der zugspitze heute mittag
beweist das wird sich aber ändern denn
es wird kälter
heute nacht sinken die temperaturen im
binnenland auf plus 4 bis minus 1 grad
es droht also verbreitet bodenfrost muss
kann auch glatt sein denn es fällt ja
regen und der zieht im laufe der nacht
hier allerdings richtung nordseeküste ab
es kommt aber neuer regen heran und zwar
hier über dem bodensee und dieser regen
der breitet sich morgen über tag von
baden württemberg weiter aus über bayern
über hessen und thüringen sachsen anhalt
bis nach berlin und brandenburg und so
ab den späten nachmittagsstunden kann es
dann morgen auch schneien und zwar im
schwarzwald und auf der schwäbischen alb
am freundlichsten wird es morgen im
nordwesten da scheint nämlich häufig die
sonne die temperaturen steigen auf 7 bis
10 grad kühler bleibt es im thüringer
wald mit 5 und am alpenrand mit 3 grad
am samstag regnet es dann kräftig in der
osthälfte und oberhalb von 700 metern
kann es in den östlichen mittelgebirgen
auch schneien
deutlich ruhiger geht es danach weiter
schönen abend noch